let's convert the mixed number 3 and 2
29 to an improper fraction so the best
way to think about this or one way to
think about this 3 and 2 29 is the same
thing as 3 plus
2
29
and then we could actually try to add
these two things together and if we're
going to add them we need a common
denominator so we need to rewrite 3 as
something over 29. so we could rewrite
this as 3 over 1. let me do this let me
just rewrite it so this is the same
thing as 3 over 1 plus 2 over 29 the
least common multiple of 1 and 29 is
going to be 29
so it's going to be something over 29
plus 2 over 29. if we multiplied our
denominator by 29 we're gonna have to
multiply our numerator by 29 3 times 29
what is that that's 87 let's see 3 29
times 3
9 times 3 is 27 2 times 3 is 6 plus 2 is
8. 87 and if you wanted to know how i
did it in my head i just said well 3
times 3 times 30 would be 90 and this is
going to be 3 less than that because
it's one we're multiplying one we're
doing 29 times 3 instead of 30 times 3
so instead we go 3 times 30 is 90 3 less
is 87 so that's one way to do it in your
head but now we're ready to add 87 over
29 plus 2 over 29 is equal to we have
our denominator of 29 87 plus 2 87 plus
2 is 89
89 and it looks like we're done i don't
think these two things share any common
factors in fact 29 is a prime number and
as far as i can tell i think 89 might
also be a prime number let me think
about it yup 89 also looks like a prime
number so we're done we've written this
as a mix as an improper fraction the
numerator is greater than or equal to
the denominator a quick way to think
about it is we could just literally take
29 times 3 gives you 87 87 plus 2 is 89
89 over 29 89 over 29.